will be his 14th start of the season
letting everybody know it is go time
to chopper short stop and the toss
wendell tillaud
that takes care of seattle in the first
brandon lau will open the bottom of the
first when we come back
and chris flexon this will be his 20th
start 9-5 record at 3-8-1 era
strike three call great pitch g
manchester rang up i'll head that bobble
and the baron is let's see if they can
take advantage of it here's catcher cal
raleigh
and he swings at this one and misses and
is out on strikes two men left we go to
the bottom of ending two no score
[Music]
get hard type france nicely done there's
one they get the back end yes they do
three six three a lovely number
ty's played a good first base
this is something else that we talked
about with flexon
gets runners on he's found a way to get
out and typically it's the double play
the mayors have turned 16 double plays
behind flexon
well kevin kiermeier getting out of the
eighth spot gets an opportunity with two
outs
needing out here
swing and a miss he got him they got the
out he needed stranding a couple we go
to the third scoreless
good runner at first jp's at third kyle
popped up the third his first at bat
here's the 1-1
swung on smashed into right field that's
a base hit j.p crawford will stampede
home mitch haniger will hold at second
base as the mariners at the first run of
the ball game a ringing single from kyle
seeger it is one-nothing mariners
well the marin is hoping to do in this
series what they didn't do over in texas
hit with runners in scoring position the
mary's had all kinds of base runners
scott service talked about that on his
pregame show but kyle seeger comes
through right here and for the year kyle
banning 337 with runners in scoring
position
so here comes ty france grounded out his
first time
pitch to tie
swung on lasered into right field that's
down for a base hit mitch hannigar into
third base he's being waved around here
he comes steaming home he scores
into third base goes kyle seeger as ty
france drives in a run the mariners
extend the lead it is two to nothing
ty france stays on this breaking ball
and hits it sharply the other way into
right field great piece of hitting right
there by france kind of hangs out over
the plate had to reach for it a little
bit but he still hit it hard the other
way to drive in a run
paranoise as a team five grand slams
barely got one back in anaheim on june
5. 2-0 pitch
braley hits it hard through into right
field scoring is seeger
france on the move
he scores a two-run single for jake
fraley back off the coven iv or il
and a four nothing lead for the mariners
here in the third did get a good pitch
to hit 2-0
and hit it hard second base hit for him
drives in a couple of runs fraley at
first base toro at second mariners four
on the board were in the third no outs
swung on
ripped right to wendell on the backhand
throws to second for one they get the
out there the relay it skips on by choi
it nearly goes into the crowd toro
around third base he's going to come in
and score
scampering to second is terrence and the
mariners get another run looked like for
a moment it was going to be a double
play instead the throw went bad and the
mariners had their fifth run of the
inning a good throw would have been a
double play wendell to his right to
backhand it over to brandon lau at
second as you mentioned for the out on
fraley and lau was able to clear but a
low throw and g-man choi at first base
wasn't able to pick it it was a bounce
right in front of him that's a tough one
right there you don't know if it's going
to flatten out on you or come up high it
came up high and it got on by choi and
the mariners get another run
here's the 3-1
swung on lifted the other way long run
here comes fraley goes to the dive and
he makes a spectacular catch
jake fraley superman laying out full
extension makes the grab in the gap
taking away extra bases from lao
sensational play for the mariners left
fielder that was outstanding a rope into
left center field off the bat of brandon
lau and jay fraley completely parallel
with the turf out there left center
field diving way to his left able to get
to it belly flops and slides on his
stomach he had so much momentum behind
that that drive
what a catch by fraley
so now crawford is on to third base with
two outs five-nothing mariners top of
the fourth that'll bring up ty france
oh he jumps on this pitch drives it to
the gap nobody's gonna get a glove on it
off the fence
scoring easily is jp crawford a stand-up
rbi double time france and the mariners
have a six nothing lead at tampa bay in
the fourth inning
back to back rbi knocks for ty
his 24th double is 47th run batted in
that fastball
belt high middle in
exit v low of 102.
seems he's just getting the barrel to
everything six nothing seattle fourth
inning two and one
here comes swinging a drive on a liner
to deep center field count it going back
turning and looking it's gone
a line drive homer over the center field
wall by randy a rosarina and the race
get their first run at 6-1 seattle
15th homewood of the season for randy
and that one came off the bat at about
111. it had that sound and
didn't hit it all that high but
he was able to just tuck it up
tuck it right above the yellow line on
the wall and just took a
fastball that caught a lot of the plate
a lot of his barrel
swept by the mariners in a four-game
series in seattle there's a shot off the
bat of kevin kiermeier that's going to
bound to the wall kiermeier already on
his way to second turning the bag heads
to third and he's in there
standing up for the triple
you know the home run by roger reinder
with two outs in the fourth now a
leadoff triple by kirbyer see if that
can bring some life to the race well i
think that it will that just a center
cut fastball right there and kiermeier
once this ball gets by kilning
it's going to be tough to keep him
at second base this ball was stroked
and off he goes and starts to pick it up
realizing third base is going to be
a pretty good option
standing up
3-2 and a chopper back toward the mound
the play is gonna be at first with kier
meyer streaking home
so the rays pick up a run
on the
tap their second round of the game and
now it's 6-2 hey friends set at night
he'll stand in with two hits a double a
single two rbis he'll lead off the
seventh from the stretch just 3-1
swung on and blasted to left field this
is crushed how far is this gonna go way
back near the isle way and left center
field
ty france just destroyed a ball
demolished it
a solo home run his 11th his third hit
of the ball game and the mariners add to
the lead
7-2
as ty france goes yard in a big big way
his last home run
was a long home run way out the left
center field that was at globe life
field in texas that came at the top of
the ninth inning that tied the game at
three and this one was just the you're
right it was demolished
two outs runner at second
jake freddie is jared kellnick
hit hard base hit for jk here comes
fraley he's going to score and the
mariners have an 8-2 lead rbi jared
kellnick is 14. and the stolen base pays
off just slowly but surely starting to
crawl out of this thing and yeah solid
base hit